babec route c'est très gentil d'accord
mais je veux pas voir quelqu'un
ok mais par rapport à moi par rapport à
ma maman enfin si tu veux tu pourrais
premier casting pour chérel le temps de
quelques minutes elle devient sofia une
enfant drôle espiègle qui sera la fille
d'omar sy dans un nouveau film pourquoi
tu cours tu voulais pas son rôle déjà
joué avec omar sy est pas parce que j
aime bien le faire dès du cinéma une
ambition partagée par de nombreuses
petites filles âgées de 7 à 12 ans le
casting se déroulait à trappes ville
d'origine de l'acteur c'est bon si tu es
bien on m'a pris en photo - demandé hier
un test
et voilà c'est un acte qui motivent ma
fille elle regarde même sur sa chaîne à
des portables et ça fait plaisir
on cherche le personnage il ya des
passages test ne dort dans le texte ya
un moment il n'y a que le personnage qui
sera le dire comme il faut et c'est la
vérité du casting terre c'est après
l'accumulation quand on a vu beaucoup de
gens on commence à en savoir plus son
personnage on sait qu elle est marrante
on sait que elle rigole bien avec son
père
la comédie intitulée le prince oublier
sera réalisé par michel hazanavicius
oscarisée en 2012 pour the artist
ce nouveau film avec omar sy sera tourné
cet été 2010 8 en région parisienne